young Sudanese men raised their
automatic weapons in the air as they
join the fight against the rapid support
forces some of them are just children in
videos circulating online civilians
appear to be picking up arms alongside
Sudan's Armed Forces new recruits
forming a makeshift Army ready to
replace a failing
military according to eyewitnesses
fighters from the rapid support Force or
rsf have reached areas north of Sinar a
city where many of the displaced have
fled
to the mobilized individuals who
answered the call of the army Commander
should be trained and armed under the
control of the Sudanese Armed Forces to
avoid seeing them converting into an
independent armed
[Applause]
group there have been reports that both
the Army and the rsf have forced
civilians to joined their ranks in the
past one thing is for sure many Sudanese
people have fewer and fewer options left
fleeing or fighting last week saw the
fall of w madani Sudan's second largest
city now under the paramilitaries
control a turning point in the war the
Army's Retreat from the city left the
country in a state of panic as the rsf
makes breakthroughs in the South its
Fighters are reported stealing people's
cars cell phones and raiding stores
there is massive movement as rep support
forces Advance onward mad and other
Sudanese Armed Forces withdraw from this
T towns often without putting up a fight
uh the Panic of the idps and the local
populations in these areas tell us that
the rep support forces have earned a
reputation of plunder of abuse of
massive Recreation against areas
population in areas they come to occupy
militarily one of the few safe zones in
the country what madani in Jer state was
engulfed by violence in a matter of days
up to 300,000 sudanes have fled the city
since the fighting began as the rsf make
more gains in jazer state some are
gearing up to fight with an Army in
disarray While others try to escape
fearing they could be next IPM gfood Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer